and our next speaker is mr raja vermin
kitu and he'll be highlighting and
telling us about india's technology
infrastructure in india and its
application
to talk about mr raja verman he has
completed his master's in bioinformatics
from shannon art science technology and
research academy his expertise lies in
bioinformatics computational biology
genomics ngs comparative genomics cancer
genomics and he has also worked as a
senior technical officer our clinical
bioinformatician at kokilab
ambani hospital and we are pleased to
have you with us
can you just confirm they can hear me
clearly because you can see my screen
yes so we can hear you clearly and
answer your screen
yeah sure
um
here
so currently we are going to see what is
the infrastructure generally needed for
the ngs uh so i'm just comparing nvss to
c c innocence the s ac
so since there is so much of varieties
there's so much of things to explore
uh we are going to surf in the sea now
right literally the ocean let's see how
it goes forward
so the main thing which you need to know
is ngs size when i say size it means the
file which about which come out of any
given machine is basically different
very different the file format as well
as the individual file sizes
starting from mb to gb
so in that case the size really matters
when it comes in place right second one
is which machine you are going to handle
and what are the applications you do the
third one is the checklist for readiness
when we say we're going to do the ngs
what are the things we need to have in
place
uh
let's go into detail
as i told before the smaller organisms
really using mbs and this
let's say human data you can go still
3.3 for 1x so in that case when we
consider for 3x 1000 x it's going to be
bigger and bigger
so uh this is not just to scare you
rather than to make sure
this is really the the big data which is
a buzzword which is happening in the ip
industry it's literally happening in the
biologist
so it's up to the depth so it's up to us
to decide how much that we are going and
how big the data is
uh again the second thing which we need
to know very clearly is
the data flow
when i say data flow it means how
frequently we are going to run the
machine in essence what are the samples
we are going to load how many samples we
are going to reload how frequently we
are going to operate the machine right
second one is deep sequencing as i told
how much depth we are going is it like
50 x 100 x or 2 px 500 x so it's more
than that even uh sometimes people go
for even ten percent
based on the question which we are
asking the scientific question we are
asking that that can go
uh like probably vary right
and the last one which is very important
is what kind of family you're going to
run this is just a basic panel with a
limited number of genes probably the
targeted genes for the full exam or the
whole genome or holism
right so these three things has to be
anyway
basically uh for any given english data
set we'll be having a raw data process
data and we'll be going for wrapping
apart from the clinical setup we might
even need to do the re-analysis or we
need to review the dataset so what do
you mean by reanalysis suppose down the
line so there is there are steps where
we will be going for annotation for the
given variance so that will be changing
with respect to time for certain number
of genes right so those kind of cases
where reanalysis
is important based on that even the
therapy recommendation might vary not in
the bigger level but in the slight
slight deviation spending are possible
so in this case we analysis is one of
the key factor so we need to be knowing
what are the things will be permanently
archived and whatever the files are
probably whatever the details we need to
have always collecting ready so that we
need to go for re-analysis apart from
when i say review it means say uh five
years you have some analysis
you want to recollect in the five years
what are the variants like very commonly
acquired from the given dataset
and probably you can even find the
trendings in the sense the reason two
years what are the new variants about
what are the reasons findings are from
the given dataset so those kind of
repurpose related analysis
this module like the second part has to
be considered so in that case when we
really go for the data management we
need to know what are the regular
accessories and what are the repurposes
based on the needs and the application
we need to be sure about which one we
are choosing and whether it is solving
all of the questions or not
to solve all the questions which we
asked right
the first is purpose as i told uh
whether you asking a basic question or
intermediate or advanced whether the
given technology will help us to answer
this one the second one is sample mode
how as i told before how frequently
you're operating the machine how much
load
are you having
to
have it or handle it
last one is the capacity whether are we
having high throughput machine or
clothing machine right so these are the
key points which has to be checked
beforehand
so uh i was keep on speaking about the
missions so when i say missions it means
as you can see the varieties start from
starting from 1.2 gb to
6000 gb so this is the capacity for the
single run
when we uh fully utilize the machine uh
to a full extent right
so as i told before
these are all the uh
let's say low throughput and this is a
mid throughput and this is the high end
right
and
these
where do we use a low throughput machine
for sequencing the smaller organs we
need bacterial virus fungus in any given
smaller organisms except the human for
the whole genome sequencing it can be
used so particularly for a smaller
organism this sequencing machine is
being used right and
apart from this even the sample number
is less
and we need to have like say as i told
before 0.2 1.2 gb right so those kind of
smaller amount of data if you want to
visit let's say generate this kind of
facility is fair enough right
when we are going for bigger projects
say population studies or coherent
related analysis those kind of bigger
studies if you want to do probably we
need to have this kind of hiring even
including the kovid sequencing data set
we need to have these kind of missions
in place
right for example when it comes to
genome sequencing and volume systems
right
and apart from that
when the sample node is higher even
though it's a smaller than one but your
sample load is very higher so in that
case probably you'll be using this this
kind of sequences right so this is going
to give high throughput
is in the clinic and research it's been
widely used academy it's truly coming up
so we would like to see more uh
the missions which we discussed uh in
the in the probably the focusing
features right
application wise if you see as i told
before you name it any given application
of genomics it can be performed
with the machines which we discussed
whole genome sequencing whole expensive
mutilation signature hla cgd pgs
comprehensive panel targeted panels rna
so you name it any kind of application
everything can be done right
so
okay we know about the background now uh
can we list out what are the key points
to do that we should be having to
proceed
so
the first one is security uh why because
there are very sensitive data has been
uh used in the us probably the medical
data sets
where
we don't reveal much details everywhere
rather every all the patient will be
converted to the particular id and that
will be processed
in that case even the data access will
not be given to everybody
since there is a hipaa aggregated uh
certifications are given to the
informatics tools security is the first
constraint right second one is user
friendliness
since uh it's not like everyone is
mastering the informatics to do
so in that case the friendliness is
user-friendliness is very important
third one is basically audit trials of
file access why
uh when it comes to clinical setup
specifically
which file has been accessed by home at
what time that will be traced out
because that's very important thing to
back not only the batteries
even to uh there are multi levels of
screening will be done
to release the report even those kind of
places this audio trial is very
important right and the fourth point is
basically manpower as i told
establishing the full facility
starting from scratch to a reporting
solution is
basically needs a
really good number of clan cover who is
very much speed
and apart from that
we need to have a good battery backup
for the separate lecture to have
infrastructure and the room temperature
should be monitored for 365 days
apart from that good internet speed is
needed why we these other things are
needed since we are speaking about
6000 gb data set from one particular one
you can imagine
how long it takes to transfer the data
set process the analysis and then
archiving it so in this case these all
the basic needs should be in place
right
so uh
say i'm very new i'm from academic uh
since i do i can't go for all kind of
thing i have only simple laptop can you
do the ngs analysis yes you can do
probably if you see there is a there are
there are software like galaxy and there
are even some pipelines which is ready
made are available which can be used
using even windows but typically if you
want to do in in-house without sharing
data with any of the third party
probably outsiders in that case this is
the computation which is expected like
this is a ram this thing is
are problems storage is 50 db and linux
works it's very difficult to get as a
workstation probably as a server linked
with the workstation is good to go with
so in that case you start with
complicated to answer the
questions right
of computation complicated
so
i got the facility now i got the setup
now in place what are all the basic
thing i need to check to make sure my
data is good enough to do the analysis
first thing you need to know is coverage
like whatever the panels are sequence
have i have got all the data set in
place second one is dip
like whatever the depth i estimated have
i reached the definitions how many x uh
depth have you used right reads there
are cases where in rna kind of dataset
you have to know how many leads have
been generated whether they start enough
to proceed further
and the third one is machine as i told
which machine should i process to get
these kind of data sets and uh sample
number as i said before how many samples
can occur
in one particular batch if i could just
sample this particular batch how much of
coverage and depth will i do so those
kind of pre-calculation estimation
should be well defined so that the
expected results are in place
and files to preserve as i told before
which other things should be archived
permanently
should be in the front desk so that
anytime you can access that part should
be very much well defining exceptions
and finally the process so before even
process
i would say there has to be a testing
phase or probably the beta version
should be there in place to make sure
yes every individual process is
going well without any disturbance right
when it comes to research setup probably
open source tool if you plan to use how
does it grows this is how the overall
workflow goes
the literature cell will be
conducted based on whatever the tools
which is why we didn't use and the same
tools will be downloaded and then we'll
be standardizing based on the data set
and the question which we asked
so when i say summary which means
fine-tuning the parameters when i say
validate it means same kind of study is
being absorbed
from the pubmed by publications and then
replicating the same work so that to
make sure yes my tool is meeting the
standards which is being already
published so that is a validation and
finally the pipeline again
every individual uh application which we
discuss have its own pipeline in the
steps every steps will be validated with
the relevant parameter and then we will
be going to the final product right so
this is a protocol which has been
followed for in-house development so in
this case the complication is really
very high always skill
so in that case
there are alternative solutions which is
there in market which is basically
the softwares are already feeding the
parameters are really quick it's very
easy to use in that case cloud solutions
are available which can be used apart
from that there are some uh servers
which comes with
fpga card where all the programs
programs are already feeded validated
and standardized the moment you uh
probably it's been installed from the
day one it can be used so uh i'm not
going into these two topics much why
because uh
we are mostly going to speak about
infrastructure
with that i'm just closing the stop if
you have any if you have any
thank questions so much mr raj verman
for your presentation
if you have any questions for sir please
put them in the chat box and we will be
able to
get a question answered
and also those participants who are
asking about the recordings yes we'll be
sharing with you the recordings very
soon for that you need to fill out the
registration form so that we have your
email ids at least where we can uh share
the recordings with you all so we just
put the registration from the list in
the chat box and those who have
not registered themselves they can fill
the phone
okay so sir i wanted to ask the question
what are the career opportunities with
prema's life sciences
okay uh currently
since you took the name
psd
we train the people in the analysis we
train the people for preparing the
libraries and loading the samples plus
we
see when we have a specific marketing
team who takes care of uh probably all
the marketing activities and the sales
team so in that case we have opening
almost in all the departments at this
different point
so if you are asking specifically
informatics uh i don't there might be a
junior level intimate uh
intern opportunity might be available
but not a full-time job but with other
segments there are two things observed
thank you so much and the next question
is what could be the possible online
resources for ngs based identification
of microbial variety
okay so
when you say the database is already in
place for almost all the model organisms
the sequencing data which the process
data as well as the sequencing data is
in place particularly when i say when
you say a smaller organism i can think
about two things quickly which is mtb
and kobit kobe data is anyway it spits
out with uh decide actually uh
at the same time even ncb sra has to
name it any kind of application
everything is already in place so this
is a few resources which i can think
about quickly
right and this linux are masks for
engines by
informatics what are your thoughts on it
is
linux yes the question is is linux a
must for ngs bioinformatics
[Music]
okay is linux is important okay so
i would say the linux is even
i think the voice is breaking no
so the linux is important i don't think
so it is important because
as i told the last slide
uh the cloud computing solutions which
is which are coming up which are in the
market currently doesn't need any skills
at all so it's based on which solution
you are looking for if you are like say
if we are skilled in the let's say
probably the scripting as well as the
linux commands then probably there are
certain tools which is again the fpga
card related uh tools are probably
developing their own pipeline can be
done if not then there are cloud
solutions which is alternative for
uh people who are very new to
informatics or not aware of implementing
so we have both kind of solutions
available
exactly
and the other questions we uh then be
taking up some thank you so much sir for
your talk and answering the questions
yes